Hello! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Mr. Massagy
the totally platonic and not sexual in any way game about...
...meeting people who are very normal and not weird and
having a great time with them
and i don't know why I'm getting louder IT'S OKAY
Anyway.
So, getting back into-
*coughs*
So we're getting back into Mr. Massagy
because for some reason you guys wanted...
...ALOT more...
...of this game and i'm, not 100 percent sure why?
On the surface it didn't seem too...
...you know...
*screaming* ...not sexual...
Anyways, so i'm just gonna...
...if i could remember how to play.
No...
No..
No.
No (x4)
Kill duck?
What the heck is kill duc- i already killed duck
kill duck is right there-
dead duck-
that's 100 percent a dead duck right in the corner of my god damn screen.
I can't exactly say in any other way that there's a dead duck over-
anyway whatever.
No
Who the hell is Martha?
Have I gone on a date with Martha?
Martha's Linger description: "I'm looking for a sexy man, I love traveling. #ThatsHowIRoll"
Alright then you seem-
uh, nevermind mind then.
Change the profile
alright then. How about this?
This sexy guy on my phone.
There's a sexy guy on your screen,
it's me
*Markiplier doing a weird*
So if i-
I donno
It's a match!
You and martha like ea-
*Markiplier transforming into his final, beautiful and even more handsome form.*
I forgot about the transformation.
*Markiplier reading a random fact.*
And you're also a flashing rainbow who dances through the sky
and has babies with aliens...
Anyway
Johnny is having an online date with Martha.
Oh. Okay, alright then.
Hi Martha!
Hi...
'sup
How's it goin'
Martha: "So... right. Hey, you have a cute nose."
Uh.
Thank you- *interrupted by laughing*
You have a cute-
actually, you're not cute at all.
Hey wait a minute... you look nothing like your profile pic!
Martha: "Don't be silly! That there profile pic is a drawing, not a photograph! Can't ya tell the difference between reality and fiction?"
Martha: "But that is a cartoon of me when i was 19. When i worked as a lingerie model."
Okay?...
oh jiggly...
Martha: "I used to work for Gicci and Banana, did i tell you that already?
They commissioned that picture from some famous French guy. But I got lost in Paris shortly after!"
Okay this story makes no god damn sense at all
I just got into this game and I don't understand a single thing that you're saying
OHHKAy I'm getting Massagy Points
Martha: So they put that drawing on the milk cartons and in the paper, Oh man, was that a weird coupla days.
WOW
That sounds like a lot of BS to me!!
Except I'm wearing BLUE today so you aged like fine wine
*T-Rex noise*
That's too jiggly for my taste. You need to back down a little bit there
BAGUETTES DON'T HAVE PERSONALITIES
No matter how many times I say BONJOOOOOUUR to you!
OH PLEASE
ENLIGHTEN ME
Do I have a choice
*voice crack*
Okay.....Alright then.
*awkward weird noises*
I got a black couch you wanna..eat burgers on me
Maybe?
ahh it's still jiggling
*Laughs*
ah god you need to stop that
Well what a lovely coincidence we're having on this wonderful date that we're having here
Oh boy
That's a tiny jiggle just for the road
Alright....
Okay burgers and chill. That seems- ah
oh boy
Alright
Let's see how this massage is...
Oooh a li- oh a deep rumble
Okay... alright
okay not weird at all
Ahhh
N- no
Oh okay
This is- this- th- this is quite the-
*Mark making weird faces*
ahh its kicking into overdrive
*Stange noises*
Hey now
Thats getting the muscles
That's reliving all my stress
Yup. That's a good MASSAGE
Thanks. Alright I'm gonna leave now. Alright
That's good
I think we're good
We're good on that one
"Momma's Jelly-O. Slow and intense, the massagy for real men." *laughs*
Let's continue this....lovely dating adventure
No I'm good
Sarah...
Alright. Uggh I gotta change my profile. Hang on cycling back around
Hang on
There we go
Hi Sarah
Oh yeah
You like winners baby
*kisses bicep*
I'm the best biggest winner that you ever won
And the prize is me
Can you imagine how great I am
Oh. Only all the time. Thank you
"On Valentine's Day, 15% of women in the US send.....themselves flowers
Oh okay hi Sarah how you doin'
*Mimicking Sarah weirdly*
Sounds familiar didn't i run into a scenario like this in huniepop one time
*more weird nosies*
To lose my "virginlity"
Let's see
Well nothing says- nothing wrong about being direct
*weird noise*
uh- wha- I'm a winner baby
but I'm a winner
baby I'm a winner
Baby
I'm a-
*whispers* I'm a winner
Show how much of a winner I am
SEE!!
*weird noise*
It's a winner!!
*whispers* I don't know I'm sorry
Alright let's try this again
Alright hey baby
*mimicking Sarah*
But I gotta match this
Giv- here- Have it. I've lost it. I can't find it. Have you seen it?
heh yeah *weird noise*
*mimicking Sarah, again*
yeah I'm getting a lot of huniepop vibes from this
That's cu- That's cuz we're not dancing baby, cuz when Markiplier starts dancing the whole place sets on fire
That's why I'm banned from 13 clubs around the globe
*whispers* Fuck
We're not dancing
No I didn't, not at all
There we go
Uh, WIN
*sweet voice* I help orphan puppies
Yeah that's me I love em alot
In addition to all the unprotected sex and rock and roll
oh that's....
heh glad you noticed
Don't have many brains but i got a lot of brawn
Well ya know about 5 foot 10 ya know
Probably more than you gonna get *weird giggle*
HOW BIG DO YOU WANT ME TO BE BABY!!
HOW BIG DO YOU WANT ME TO BE!!
HUH!!
Yeah I'm a bit of a loser
HELL YEAH JOHNNY DON'T STOP DANCING FOR NOBODY!!
HELL YEAH!!
Thank you
I have been waiting for somebody to notice how lovely my ear lobe is
Oh my god, me too, I'm in love, MARRY ME
I could buy like this many
*honking noise*
THAT MANY!!
I could bu- I'd buy them all, I'd the world's supply of mojit for you
I'm funny
Did i mention I'm funny?
That was on my profile right?
That fact that I'm funny
Hope you got that
I'm bored out of my mind at this story
Ah man *weird noise*
Well...this about as well as i could have expected
I didn't- I didn't expect anything to go better than anything else in my life that's gone this way thus far
Heh what was I to hope that love would find me
I mean a massage not anything to do with love or anything or anything sexual its all about the massage
Anyway gonna try that again
Alright
So I gotta- I think to put this one on I gotta go back to my huniepop days and put on my Marki-douche mode
Where- Where my pop collar
Pop- pop my-
*Mark being awkward*
Hey
Sup
It's me
The Mark
You can call me that if you want
Maybe
Pfft I don't know
Yeah give me that
Yeah that's right
*weird noises*
Ya know what
Yeah
I'm gonna get you a mojito
uh ye- yeah cookie
Okay
Yeah I know it's good
Yeah whatever
It- ye- right unprotected sex...that's me
I'm the man
You know what i do
Not safe stuff
I rob banks with like...2 guns
Its nuts. I'm crazy. Wild even
I've got no morals
I didn't- as-
I LIKE AVOCADOS!!
They got the good fat
Ya know normally I'm very...
RAUNCHY!!
But today i think i wanna go for a slippery avocado
Oh i know
I've been told that many times. Each and every time i lost my virginity every one was like...
Woah! Hey
You're good
And then ya know life went better for me after that
yep
I know
Work out
That's nothing but true
Pfft
I'm big, real big
Biggest big you ever bigged
That big
Alright oh- okay
*lots of stuttering*
See
Money
That's what I got
Lots of it
Got a fortune
Hell yeah
O- Oh yeah
uh
Ya
Wa- t- bu-
I-
But that was my....douchy-ist
Alright this time
Mega douche mode coming in hot and heavy
Fast and strong
Virginity out the window
Completely gone from here
Ya know what else
Booze?
I've got it
All over ya
Free
No questions
Sex?
Drugs?
Love em
Cocaine?
I got mad Mike on my- on the hook up
I'm big so big
Ya know how big?
Depends on the temperature
It's kinda blamy out today
That means I'm big
Okay, alright
Fortune
Yeah that's right
Fortune?
How rich?
Too rich for words
They don't have a number for how much money I have
And you don't have a number for how much massage I'm gonna give you
I know
Ya know what else sounds like box of secrets?
My- my dick?
I dunno
I know
Hard to do
I'm the only employee
Kinda self-employed here
And i get to pick who gets to be that one
Didn't win it one day for Chica
Chicas' my dog
Don't worry about that
We'll get to that later
I'm the best
What can i say i got more than good
Yea-
Oh tripple massagy
Oh I'm already prepping
I'm ready bring it on
I'm read- I've got a deep not
That you need to relieve
Oh boy I didn't see the question again
I dunno what any of these is
What was the question?
Can i go back a step?
Nope can't do that
Well here we go...
I know the Capital of Costa Rica
No I don't thats a lie
Here we go
Okay cool
Oh i don't want to brag I'm the best at sports
I got one arm of Tom Brady
One arm of Tyler
Both too powerful for mankind to comprhend
You wanna see em?
*Mark preparing to show his bulging biceps*
Ready?
Tom Brady!
Tyler!
Together they form
A loving couple
Well that's not goddamn true apparently
I'm gonna go with the bottom one
Oh yeah
If you yell as loud as I do
EEEEVVVEEERRYONE gonna listen to no matter what you say
Hell yeah, that's me
I don't return my videos to blockbuster
Cuz its dead
All of it
OH heck yeah
Oh
wait
*in a bad Australian accent* "Ya great bastard
That was amazing"
I know
You don't need to tell me
I'm aware of how amazing I am
I'm full of amazing
Have you seen how amazing I am?
Oh too late
Nice lolly- ewww
This massage feels slightly crazy
and manipulative
And exploitative
I dunno what it is
I feel more stressed if anything after getting this massage
I dun- i don- I don't think you know what i like
Even i don't know what i like
Who the heck are you Dorothy
"I'm new in town. Looking for a gentlemanly tour guide #HighHeelsAndHappy"
I'm a great listener, Baby
Have you heard how great i listen about you?
Oh
Dorothy is it?
Oh man
Love to listen...
Oh okay
OH
You're a cow
Allllrighty then
Welp
Let me try that again with a little
I- sorry
I still have this on my neck for- I dunno what fucking reason
And i still had douche mode turned on
Let me turn on suave
*Mark speaking in a bad French accent*
I am French
Oh yes it true
I know
Oh ma chérie, bonjour to you
Bonsoir to you
I see you are lucky with a four leaf clover in your hat
Do you want to get lucky with me?
Sorry excuse my spit
Ahhh mon chérie
How i wish to drink from the milk of your tit
AHH
I'm- it's late
Alright
Own it
Here we go
*Still in a bad French accent*
How
OH
Oh mi amor
I just want to hear about your emotions all day long
Tell me
*Angrily* WHAT IS IT THAT YOU DO THAT YOU THE BEST
Oh yeah
Well I'm in need of a massage
Good thing your good work with needles
Cuz ya kno-
*softly* Oh fuck
OH HOW I COULD NOT LIST
ALL OF THE TALENTS THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR BOSOM
I bet
I wish
I wish upon a star
Star..
*sighs deeply*
Your talent is unspeakable beauty
Your cute face drives the men wild
Excuse my mix of German and French here
Its all i know
Oh
Mi amooouur
There's no one in the world,
Like me
Oh
Ah-
There's the loveliest park
Right underneath the Eiffel Tower
Where all can marvel at your beauty
Even though the sturdy iron rod structure
th-
*in Scottish? accent* The sturdy iron rod structure of the Eiffel Tower can't compare to the beauty of yer buns
*French accent again* Oh
Mon chérie
Do you not know that I just won $500
And only minus one mojito
I will spend every dollar of it on you
Ahh
I TRIED MY BEST
*still in a bad French accent*
Wait
I can do better
But it's going to be the expedited
*expedited slowed down*
French version
*Mark saying random things in a bad French accent*
Well
Ahh
If i ever saw a more bus??(idk) like
Body
Than the one that you have on ye
I would be remised to ever notice the *kissing nosies* the deliciousness that lies with your thighs
No i never pull out the French/Irish/German for anybody but special ladies
OHH
*no accent anymore* Here we go
I'm ready
*with accent again* Without your hat
Your little eyes is beautiful
your robust frame is just, enticing me so, I can't ever imagin-
*without accent* I don't know what accent I'm doing
I'm gonna drop the French
Hey baby nice cow ass
Well I'm outta here
That's a good joke to end this on
I think i can live happily with my life choices now
And sleep soundly at night
Anyway
So..
That's probably all for this episode of Mr. Massagy
I think there's four people to swoon left so um...
Yeah I'll probably finish this one out
Thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought of this
And let me know what you thought of my french accent
Down in the comments below
Be honest
It was great wasn't it
Alright anyway
So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always i will see you
In the next video
Buh-bye!